hey what's up guys my name is Samuel
Leeds and on this video I wanted to
explain what you need to be a deal
sorcerer which is a deal package a
someone who finds deals and passes them
on to investors for a fee you can be
very wealthy doing this is submit many
of my students do so I just wanted to
give you the lowdown on how to be a deal
packager please do smash the like button
below and don't forget if you haven't
already subscribed to this channel so
what do you need to be a deal sauce or a
deal packager well let me just take what
it is in case anyone doesn't exactly
understand a deal package is someone who
finds good deals now the best ones of
course they can keep themselves but you
find deals and then you pass them on for
a fee and typically a fee will be
anywhere between about 2,000 and 5,000
pounds so if you just found and passed
on one property per month which might
take you a day a month then you could
replace a full time income and this is
the one of the reasons why so many
people are becoming to deal packages
these days so what do you need to be a
deal packager there's four things that
you need to have in place number one is
you need deals get it deals you've got a
deal packager if you can't get good
deals so that's the first thing that's
only one of the four things sometimes
people think and I think that just
because they're grey of finding property
deals there's something gonna be gonna
be really rich and that's not
necessarily the case because there's
three more things but it is vitally
important it's probably the most
important thing that you need because if
you can't find good deals
I mean people as well some people want
to be a deal packager and they're trying
to network and stuff but they're not
even good at finding a deal so it's the
first thing you just need to be good at
finding deals the second thing is you
need investors you need people to sell
those deals too so I mean how do you how
do you build your investor list where
you can go networking you can advertise
you can you can put publicize the fact
that you're a property investment your
deal source not on social media you can
go through property events and find
people that are looking because
sometimes a property event or property
training event there's some people in
the room
that I've got loads of money but very
very little time and there's some people
in the room that have got loads of time
but they're making money they can't they
can't buy anything himself very easily
so and events like this at networking
and training events you can hook up with
the people who've got who've got the
money but having all the time and then
you can pass them deals and add them to
your investor list you can go to
auctions when people well when an
auction goes on they go to buy a
property and there's only one person
that ends up buying the property all the
other people are disappointed a lot ah
well why not go approach to
disappointing people as I know it's
annoying that we missed out on that deal
hey I've got some properties that
they're really lucrative in the area
would you be interested in me send you
some details across you know that when
you're when you're a deal packager the
person with the biggest investor list
wins so you should be building your
investor list all the time that's the
second deal third thing is you need to
be compliant there are some rules and
regulations around deal packaging
because because the thing is that this
is if there was no rules and regulations
then there would be people going around
with fake deals and promising things
that can't be true lying about what the
rental income will be and what the
market value is of the property and
selling properties to investors the who
and naive and then it's just going to
end in tears and this is going to be
court cases and all kinds of stuff so as
a result of that there are rules and
regulations so you need indemnity
insurance so before you can start
selling properties and setting up a
damage insurance you need a limited
company you need a business and a bank
account to actually take the money you
also need to be registered with a
property redress scheme such as the
property Ombudsman why do you need to do
that so that if there's a dispute you
don't have to have an argument with the
person you know if the investor says you
never told me this you can down the line
there's a problem then they have they
can don't speak to the property
Ombudsman and then this is not
particularly expensive it doesn't cost a
lot to register with a property
Ombudsman you also need to have anti
money laundering to make sure that
you're not doing this for unscrupulous
reasons to trial or money so that there
are there are some regulations like this
it's not too complicated it's not too
expensive I'd recommend Alastair
Cunningham's book it's called whatever
it takes and in that there's a whole
chapter dedicated to how to be a
compliant deal sorcerer so that's the
third thing that you need it's really
important the fourth thing that you need
is a deal sources you need a good
reputation massive mega mega mega you
need a good reputation and and when
you've got a good reputation I always
think when you get in with just one or
two good property investors then
suddenly they'll with the same people or
buy deals with you sometimes every month
we've got a guy James Armstrong who's
one of our property investors Academy
members and he makes like thousands and
thousands and thousands of pounds every
month through deals sourcing the old
packaging but he's only got a handful of
investors but the same investors from
Hong Kong and Australia and India they
just buy they just buy properties often
over and over again why do they do that
because he's got a good reputation so
those are the four things that you need
to be a professional deal sorcerer you
deals investors to be compliant and you
need a really good reputation if you're
just starting out as a deal sorcerer and
you think oh my gosh I have any
investors I haven't got I'm not
complying I haven't got the money to
become compliant I haven't got the the
reputation because I'm just getting
started what on earth can I do well you
could use something called Co deal
sourcing we call this slipping
Cody else or Seng is where you find a
property deal source who's got a good
reputation
who's compliant has got a good investor
list but he's struggling with deals he's
struggling to find deals you go and find
the deals pass them to the to this
sorcerer he will sell it for you and
then you can come up with some kind of a
profit share on the money or the fee
that's made it's a fantastic strategy is
something that a lot of people do when
they come through the property investors
crash course that I run is a two day
program so Cody you're sourcing and
everything you can do if you haven't got
the money to become compliant you
haven't got the investors to you buddy
struggling its pass a deal on to so on
for free and then document the journey
and say look I'll give it you for free
on the condition that you give me a
testimonial and then suddenly how many
testimonies you need to have a good
reputation one if you've got one
powerful testimonial from somebody it
shows that you are the real deal to some
extent
and then as a result of that you can
then you'll have confidence yourself and
then you can then start charging people
as well so so there's lots of ways to
get started what you need to do is you
just need to be creative you need to be
prepared to do whatever it takes I'm
gonna put a link to Alice there's book
below whatever it takes unless they're
coming up is one of my students has
become a ridiculously successful
property sorcerer he makes between
thirty and fifty thousand pounds every
single month through property sourcing
so it can be extremely lucrative I think
everyone should be a deal sorcerer
because even if you don't want to set up
a business and do it really hardcore and
do what I stairs down and make thirty
fifty grand a month if you want to do
that but you do want to buy properties
for yourself sometimes you don't get
about to buy a property that you say it
might not fit your strategy or it might
not be in your area or it might be
perfect but you might have like what
sometimes when you went in for a bus and
then to come at once is the same your
property you waiting for a property one
comes you're like yes I can buy it but
then another two or three come up and
you're like I'll buy all of them so it
makes sense to be able to then pass them
on and get a fee and then put it towards
your own properties so sort of great
business because you can cherry-pick the
best deals for yourself while you can it
paid to look at properties which is just
fantastic so I really recommend deal
sourcing I think it's a great business
just make sure you do it properly stick
to those four things if you want further
training you can either come on one of
my programs property investors crash
course which is a two day free program
with me personally where we find deals
when we sauce deals all over the weekend
or whatever the program is but also if
you've got questions not coming below
and I'll do my best to answer as many
questions as I can and help you that way
because I want a mission to help people
become financially free through property
believe it or not I have a tally chart
next to my bed every time someone become
financially free put a little dot a
little tip next to it and your success
really is more oxygen so peace out I'll
see you next time thank you so much for
watching this video it's mentoring on a
Monday every single week at 7 p.m. on a
Monday between 8 p.m. I'm gonna be live
answering all your comments and
questions don't forget to subscribe
right over here so you'll never miss one
of these videos I'll see you next week
at 7 p.m.
also if you haven't got a copy of my
book you need this in your life you can
get it from Amazon for 10-pound launch
and I
or a gift from made absolutely free down
below in the description link I'll see
you next week Monday at 7 p.m.